à la nuit tombée les maisons de la rue
de l'ancienne mairie à montigny le
bretonneux s'illuminent pour laisser
place à la féerie de noël une licorne
des champignons ou encore des pingouins
venue du pôle nord qui est venu sandrine
est ravi de partager ses décorations
avec les passants gros bonhommes de
neige plus on pouvait voir avec ces
petits flocons ensuite on passe par le
petit passage nous avons la famille de
serre le papa et la maman et son bébé
des décorations qui représente tout de
même un budget conséquent d'un budget le
rennes c'est 150 euros à peu près le
bonhomme de neige aussi
oui je l'avais eu chez gifi en 50 % je
l'avais acheté après les après les
décorations faites quand ils solder tous
et la décoration de lidl 8 euros et
chaque année sandrine enrichit un peu
plus sa collection le but est également
d'illuminer le visage des enfants qui
passent devant sa maison se trouve que
c'est plus gai et en plus comme on
habite juste en face l'école ma les
enfants ça leur permet de d'égayer un
peu leur fin d'année qui est avec cette
année hugo vide un peu compliqué je
trouve que c'est un peu de joie dans ce
monde un peu compliqué à 48 heures de
noël les passants de la rue de
l'ancienne mairie peuvent encore
patienter en lumière avant de retrouver
leurs cadeaux au pied du sapin
[Musique]